When a fast food worker is fired from an Arby's restaurant, he discovers the PERFECT revenge.
And then we travel to Mexico to take a look at a minute by minute account of what happens
after a UFO crashes.
While the Mexican government AND the CIA are both rushing to the scene of this fallen alien
ship, little do they know they're both about to become participants.
In a mass casualty event.
Today on Dead Rabbit Radio.
Hey everyone, welcome back to another episode of Dead Rabbit Radio.
I'm your host Jason Carpenter and I'm having a great day.
Hope you guys are having a great day too.
Hope you guys had a fun weekend.
We got a lot of stuff to cover so we're gonna go ahead and get started right away.
Walking into Dead Rabbit Command is one of our newest Patreon supporters.
Everyone on your feet and give it up for Hammer.
Wooo yeah!
Come on in Hammer.
Thank you so much for joining the Patreon.
Hammer you're gonna be our captain, our pilot this episode.
If you guys can't support the Patreon, I totally understand.
Just helps with the word about the show that really, really, really helps out a lot.
Now Hammer, let's go ahead and toss you the keys to the Dead Rabbit Durgible.
We're gonna leave behind Dead Rabbit Command.
We are gonna fly all the way out to Missouri.
And I hope you guys brought a lunch, but I hope you guys have not eaten it yet.
Because this story is disgusting, not just because we're going to an Arby's, the worst
of all fast food restaurants.
I would rather live in a Long John Silver's than eat at an Arby's.
Long John Silver's isn't that bad, but imagine if you're trying to sleep.
People don't live in Long John Silver's, but you know they ring that bell whenever the
service is good.
Have you guys ever been to Long John Silver's?
It's a fast food.
We didn't have a soda before.
Because there is a conspiracy theory that Long John Silver is connected to the marijuana
- allegedly is connected to the marijuana industry.
There was this drug dealer who was trying to launder a bunch of drug money and he knew
the guy who started Long John Silver, so he said, "I'll give you this money.
You can somehow convince people to eat fast food that is fish and I'm gonna launder this
money.
I'll see if I actually did that or if I just had a dream."
It is a real conspiracy theory.
I'm pretty sure I did that episode.
Long John Silver's though.
Why are we talking about Long John Silver's?
Okay, let's get to the Arby's thing.
I'm not living in Long John Silver's.
I don't need to go into their bell ringing technique.
It's if the service is good during the bell.
Anyways, has nothing to do with what we're talking about.
Apparently I'm just very hungry.
In Missouri, in the city of Lee's Summit, we actually have the exact address for this
place.
So if you want to go to this Arby's and take photographs and send them back to me, if you
want to relive this event, you can.
I don't recommend it.
On Highway 291 and Northeast Tudor Road, this story begins.
This fable of a young man begins in June of 2019.
There's a Arby's worker named Tanner Maggard.
And Tanner, he's 19 years old and he's like, "Oh, my first job."
And he walks into the Arby's and he's making roast beef sandwiches and he's like, "Preparing
french fries or whatever other food they have on your rings, I don't remember."
Because I haven't eaten there in like 20 years.
He's making all this food and he's like, "You know what?
I really love working here.
I don't just love the disgusting food.
I like the disgusting atmosphere."
He looks over at all the customers.
They're all like sloth people.
He's like, "Yeah, this is the place I've always wanted to be.
I've always wanted to work at an Arby's."
He's this poor guy.
Trust me, trust me.
You're not going to feel sorry for this guy in a little bit.
The fact that he's working at Arby's is really the high point of his life.
Tanner is working at Arby's, but he doesn't work there very long.
Because management has an issue with Tanner.
Sure, he might show up on time.
Sure, he might prepare the food correctly.
Sure, he might have service with a smile.
He also has a bad habit of setting fires in the kitchen.
Not where it's supposed to be.
He's not like lighting pilot lights or cooking food.
Apparently, I don't know if he did this on his breaks.
They're like, "If you're going to do this, at least wait until your lunch hour, Tanner."
Or if he was doing it on the clock, but he kept setting fire to the kitchen.
And for whatever reason, there's a question.
How many fires would one of your employees have to start at your place of business before
you fired him?
I think the answer would be one.
He set several fires during his time at Arby's.
He kept setting stuff on fire.
And after, I don't know, the eighth one, they're like, "Oh, we've talked about this seven times
before.
You can't set stuff on fire in the store.
You're fired."
They didn't even mean the pun.
They didn't mean the pun.
He's like, "Oh, no!"
So he's fired and he leaves.
But then, on October 19th, 2019, it's been four months since he's been unjustly fired
for trying to burn down in Arby's.
He comes back into the Arby's.
Now, I'm sure he stopped by several times between June and October.
They didn't seem super alarmed when we walked back in, but they knew he was a weirdo.
They knew this guy was a weirdo.
One, he worked at Arby's right and they all know there's something wrong with you if you
worked there.
But two, he was set up on fire.
But you know, sometimes you gotta eat where you gotta eat.
So he comes into the Arby's on October 19th and he places an order and then he goes to
the bathroom, which is usually the opposite order.
Right, normally you eat Arby's and then have explosive diarrhea.
But before he even gets the food, he places the order and he goes into the bathroom.
Then a short time later, he comes out and he tells the manager, "Oh, I see you remodeled
the bathroom."
Huh.
And then he gets his food and he sits down.
The manager's like, "Oh, man, this guy's so weird.
We didn't remodel the bathroom.
Why would he say something like that?
I'm too busy."
Basically after this exchange, Tanner goes back into the bathroom and the manager has
to go into the bathroom to clean it.
It's not for their monthly cleaning at the Arby's restaurant.
He goes into the bathroom and he's cleaning up the bathroom.
But Tanner is in a stall and when the manager's in there and he's like, "Dum-dum-dum-dum."
He's like picking up toilet paper or like wiping down the urinal, whatever.
He hears Tanner in the bathroom stall going, "Ugh."
He hears some gagging and retching.
He's like, "Oh, man, this place is hard enough to work.
It's hard enough to work here.
Now I got this dude, this ex-employee, gagging in the stall."
So the manager just trying to, I feel so bad for this manager.
He's just trying to do his job, man.
He's just trying to clean this up.
So he leaves.
Obviously, he needs to clean the whole bathroom.
Tanner's in part of it.
He's in the stall.
You don't necessarily want to ask, "Are you okay in there, buddy?"
The manager leaves the bathroom and then waits for Tanner to leave so he can finish cleaning
up.
Tanner ends up leaving the bathroom and the manager's like, "Oh, finally."
And he goes in and he opens the stall where Tanner had been previously.
And what he finds is, you know, so in a lot of restrooms, they have the baby changing
stations.
I actually think it might be required by law.
I'm not for sure, but they have those plastic things that come down so you can put, because
there's nothing you want to put your baby on than a piece of plastic that who knows
if it'll hold the weight of your baby in an Arby's bathroom.
You have the baby changing station on the baby changing station in the stall is a headless
cat.
And that would be troubling enough, right, if you walked into a bathroom and there was
a cat with no head.
Not only did the cat have no-- [laughs]
I'll call the girl pause to give you guys time to skip ahead.
Not only did the cat have no head, it was disemboweled.
It was completely mutilated.
And all over the walls of the bathroom stall and all over the toilet and all over the door
was cat blood and cat intestines.
And you know, it didn't have a head.
The head was there, apparently.
They didn't say where it was.
I don't know if it was like propped up somewhere, if it was just rolling around on the ground.
The manager's all playing hacky sack with the cat head until the police show up, because
that's what he did, obviously, this guy called the cops.
Disgusting.
And when the manager came out of the bathroom, he saw Tanner sitting in his truck in the parking
lot watching the manager, like he wanted to see what the manager's reaction was.
And then when Tanner saw him playing hacky sack with the cat head, he's like, "Oh, why
didn't I think of that?"
Tanner drove away, right when he saw the manager, right when they locked eyes, he drove away.
Now, obviously, you guys might not know this.
You guys might have never hired anybody.
But generally, when you get a job, you have to list your home address, your phone number,
your social security number, all that stuff.
So the manager just called the cops and said, "Hey, I'm a little alarmed here.
A man just eviscerated a cat in our bathroom.
And he's a known pyromaniac."
And the police said the cat didn't smell.
I didn't know this was a thing.
I thought, like, if you cut something open to my remaining zero listeners for this segment,
I thought if you cut something open, it would be stinky, right?
But apparently not.
Apparently if you kill...
Okay, I should just stop now.
But apparently if it's a fresh kill, it's less stinky.
It's not super stinky.
The reason why this is important, because if he had found a dead cat that had been, like,
roadkill for a while, they would have smelled it and they would have been like, "Oh, he
just picked a cat up off the road."
Like, he found a previously dead cat and did this.
The police go, "There's no rotten smell to this cat.
That means he just killed it."
He probably brought a live cat into the Arby's Restaurant and killed it there.
Tanner was charged with second-degree animal abuse, which really makes me think, "What's
first-degree?"
Like, if killing a cat, if bringing a cat into an Arby's, in and of itself, is an animal
abuse, killing a cat in a bathroom stall, that's second-degree.
What's first-degree?
Like, what could you possibly do that's worse than this?
Don't tell me.
Don't send me images or anything or links.
I'm just wondering.
And he also got charged with property damage because he messed up their bathroom stall.
They had to repaint it and everything.
Now, you can go, like I said, I gave you the address.
You can go check this out.
I want some of my intrepid listeners to road trip out there and see if they can detect
the blood, bring some aluminum.
I find it so fascinating, though, that how does a person like this even have a job in
the first place?
Like, how does a person like this have the wherewithal to fill out forms and put down
their social security number?
Because obviously, he's setting stuff on fire and he's killing cats.
Like, this wasn't his first rodeo, right?
It couldn't have been.
I can't imagine someone sitting there one day and be like, oh, man, I really hate that
I got fired four months ago.
I know what I'm going to do.
I'm going to kill a cat and da da da da da.
He had to have been doing this before.
Doesn't it seem like there would be a ramp up to this?
Or am I wrong?
Are people just that easy to just push?
That easy to just kind of push to the edge?
It's funny because just maybe 10 minutes before recording the segment, I was on the
Patreon Discord.
They get to listen to these episodes live.
And me and a long time listener of the show, Rudy Jazz, we're just talking about the story
of Ian Watkins, lead singer of the Lost Prophets.
This is going to get real dark real quick.
I didn't plan on this.
This literally happened 10 minutes ago, but me and Rudy Jazz were talking about Ian Watkins.
He was a singer of the Lost Prophets.
It was like this new metal band or emo metal band, whatever.
They're really big.
And apparently he started having sex with babies at some point during his career.
And the question is, was he always attracted to babies?
Or did he become attracted to babies while he was on tour with the Lost Prophets?
The rest of the band had no idea this was going on.
They had no idea at all.
They were totally flabbergasted when the cops pulled out their lead singer and they're like,
"What's he being charged for doing meth?"
Because he also did a bunch of meth.
He was also a meth head.
"What's he being charged for?
You pig.
Why are you arresting the lead singer of our band?
What is this?
Some sort of police state?"
And then the cops turned around and they're like, "Dude, we don't even want to see what
he's doing out loud.
It's so disgusting.
Just trust us.
Here's the arrest warrant."
And the rest of the band was like, "Oh my God, that guy's disgusting.
Can we go to the police station and beat him up for you?"
Like what happened?
Was he always attracted to babies or did he become attracted to babies?
Now the meth didn't help.
He might have been a totally normal person.
Meth is satanic.
Like the stuff that you go through when you're on meth is just so insane.
Who knows?
So maybe Tanner Maggard was just a normal dude who one day started setting stuff on fire.
See that doesn't track at all.
Most normal people just don't start setting stuff on fire and killing cats.
At what point did he become a psycho?
It's so fascinating.
Maybe it was something inside of him.
Maybe making one too many cheddar roast beef sandwiches drove him insane.
Who knows?
But I don't think this is the first cat he killed.
There's no other information on him.
I found this article and then he was charged with second degree animal abuse, second degree
property damage.
I couldn't find the results of the trial.
A lot of stuff that's happened, like if you were arrested in October of 2019, what was
it five months later the entire country shut down due to the pandemic?
So he's probably still facing these charges.
Maybe they've dropped him by now.
Maybe he's still wandering the streets of Lee's Summit looking for cats.
I should also say allegedly because he hasn't been found guilty.
He actually denied that he did all this stuff and then I compared him to Ian Watkins, one
of the grossest people.
So Tanner, if you didn't do this, I apologize, but if you did do this, you're sick, allegedly.
Hammer, let's go ahead and toss you the keys of the carbonicopter.
We are leaving behind this Arby's.
We are headed all the way out to Mexico.
The cats are running the helicopter.
They're like, "Save us, save us."
We're catching all the kittens that we can as Tanner's chasing them down the street.
Allegedly, we're flying out to Mexico.
I found this story the other day.
This is awesome.
This story is really cool because we hear a lot of stories about UFO crashes.
They're actually not super common, but obviously they're the big ones like Roswell.
We hear these stories about UFO crashes.
We hear these stories about retrievals like they went and they got the UFO and then they
put it on a flatbed truck.
But I've never come across a story that is so detailed.
This is almost a blow-by-blow account of what would happen if a UFO fell from the sky.
I got most of my information from a website called Mexico Unexplained.
What it sounds like, it's a paranormal UFO website that specializes in stuff that happens
in Mexico and there's a ton of it going on down there.
This article was written by Robert Bitto.
Want to give him a shout out.
Great, great story.
He got it.
The setup for the story was there was a UFO investigator.
I believe she's still alive.
There's a UFO investigator named Elaine Douglas and she got an anonymous letter, well there's
initials to it, JS, claiming to be part of something called the Deneb team, which is
a retrieval unit.
And so that's the setup for the story.
There's been like a very famous book written about this incident, but it's flowing under
the radar, no pun intended.
I thank four people in America.
I had never heard this before.
I don't know how famous it is overall, but it seems to be pretty rare.
It's not like a well known story.
However, there is actually a cover story for this as well.
It's popular enough that the government kind of had to issue a statement about it, but
very, very fascinating.
Let's get into this.
It's August 25th, 1974, 10 p.m.
And at a U.S. air defense base, all of a sudden something pops up on their monitors.
Sir, sir, come over here.
Look at this monitor.
Look at this.
He's pointing at it.
He's like, "Get your finger out of the way.
I want to see what you're pointing at."
An object is flying over the Gulf of Mexico.
It's going to enter U.S. airspace in about an hour.
It's moving at 2,500 miles per hour and it's 75,000 feet up.
Well, it's probably a meteor, right?
It's probably something that high up traveling that fast.
It's probably something...
It's a shooting star.
Make a wish, young man.
Make a wish.
Person who should be watching this machine, maybe it'll come true.
But what happens is this object begins to slow down and then turn.
It's still headed towards the U.S., but now it's coming at a different angle.
And apparently multiple people were tracking this in the United States and at first they
both thought it could be a meteor, but meteors tend not to slow down and turn.
It ends up dropping as low as 25,000 feet.
We lost it, sir.
It dropped off radar and the commander goes, "Hmm, very, very interesting."
And he walks away.
He's like, "Oh man, my wish isn't going to come true now."
That's a real tear drop.
About an hour later, radio chatter starts to pop up over the airwaves.
A Cessna, a private plane leaving El Paso, Texas headed towards Mexico City, crashed
in the desert.
Somewhere in the state of Chihuahua, near a town known as Koyami, the Cessna went down.
That was the last place they picked it up.
August 26th.
It's early morning now.
It's like between midnight and 1am.
Mexican authorities start to try to find this Cessna that crashed.
Now here's the thing.
Where it was at is where it should not have been.
They have very strict airlines in Mexico and I'm sure they have them all over the world.
And if you deviate from that, and this plane was like 40 miles off of one of these air
traffic lanes, it seems like you're smuggling drugs.
But even if it's not a drug smuggling plane, you want to see if there's any survivors.
So the Mexican authorities send out rescue teams, air rescue teams, first to spot the
wreckage to see if they can find this plane.
The Mexican government has no idea that the US government was tracking an incoming object
flying incredibly fast through the night sky.
They do not have access to that information.
So they send up their air rescue teams and as these planes are flying around looking for
this fallen Cessna, they do spot it.
At 10.30 in the morning, it takes them a long time to catch this, but because it's in the
middle of the desert, they see the smoldering wreckage of this small private plane and they
call it in.
The rescue team says, "Hey, we found the plane.
Send in ground units.
Maybe there's still some people alive."
But as this air recovery vehicle is still flying overhead, checking out the area, it
spots something else.
What they see is a silver disk that is crashed into the ground.
And from what they can tell, it doesn't seem to be damaged.
I mean, they are kind of up in the air, but it's not in pieces.
Not like the Cessna was.
They see this disk, it was about 16 feet in diameter, all in one piece, that it clearly
crashed into the Mexican soil.
So they call that in too.
They say, "Hey, we don't know what this is, but it looks like something else crashed out
here."
Maybe it collided into the Cessna.
Now like every good conspiracy theorist know, the CIA has big ears.
They're constantly listening in and they hear this.
At Fort Bliss near El Paso, Texas, the word comes in that while the Mexican authorities
were looking for a plane that crashed, most likely a drug running plane, right?
The CIA is like, "Oh no, our drugs!
I mean, they're drugs!
We have nothing to do with it!"
As the CIA are now wondering about how they're going to get more cocaine in the United States,
they hear this call come over.
They hear this call come over saying, "Hey, we saw this disk in the desert.
We don't know what it is, but when the rescue teams come out to check on the Cessna, maybe
we should send some people to the disk as well."
And the government of Mexico agreed to that.
They said, "Yeah, we'll send out military."
Because obviously this story is taking place in 1974.
People knew what a UFO was.
So they sent a military detachment to look at this disk, but even if it's not a UFO,
could be some sort of government spy craft, right?
So they do send the military out there.
They send rescue crews to the Cessna.
The CIA is intercepting all these transmissions.
They know for sure that the previous night something was coming in through the night
sky over the Gulf of Mexico, traveling extremely fast at an extremely high altitude.
Mexican government still has no access to that information.
So they go, that's obviously a UFO.
First off, we know it's not ours.
We didn't have any spy planes there.
It's possible that it is like a Russian spy plane, and if that's the case, we should go
check it out, but it could also be a UFO.
So they have all the information they need to go, except they don't have permission.
The CIA apparently, at Fort Bliss, was getting everything ready to go.
And the author, Robert Biddo, says it seems like the CIA had done this so many times that
they knew exactly how many men they needed.
They had all their equipment.
They had four helicopters, including a heavy lift super stallion copter that's used for
retrieval.
That's a real helicopter.
It's always picking up UFOs.
Sometimes it's just moving more mundane things.
The CIA gets their recovery team together and they're loading up their helicopters,
but they technically need permission.
So the US government starts to coordinate with the Mexican government and saying, "Hey,
we heard about that Cessna, that crash.
We're so sorry.
If you do have to find any drugs on that, that wasn't ours.
That wasn't the CIA moving drugs into the United States.
Would you like any help with the recovery effort?"
And the Mexican authorities were like, "No, we're good.
We're good.
Because there's possibly a UFO out there, right?"
Or the very least, some unknown spy craft.
So they say, "No, we don't need your help.
It's just a Cessna.
We can do it ourselves."
And the US government's like, "Yeah, but the Cessna might have stuff on it that you
really aren't prepared for, right?"
And the Mexican government's like, "We can take care of the Cessna because really they
just both want the UFO."
Mexican government says, "You can't come over here.
We got it taken care of."
Now the CIA is known for a lot of things, but most known for sticking their nose in business
that they don't belong in.
They're being told, "Stay away."
So the CIA goes, "You know what?
We're just going to go over there anyways."
Like, we were just being nice, asking for permission.
They take those helicopters and they leave behind Fort Bliss.
They cross the US-Mexican border.
They are headed out to the desert.
As they're flying out there, they're getting this info.
They put a spy plane, because this isn't just the CIA at this point.
Apparently, according to the story from JS, presidents involved in this, US militaries
involved in this.
They have a spy plane and they're monitoring everything that's happening in the area of
this disk crash.
Because the CIA knows exactly where it's at, because they overheard all of the coordinates,
locations, stuff like that.
And the spy plane says, "Okay, we've seen there's a bunch of military trucks have pulled up
outside of this disk.
They're actually loading it onto a flatbed."
So the Mexican authorities now have possession of this disk.
They've loaded it onto a flatbed and it's driving through the back roads.
They're not taking it in through the middle of Mexico City.
They're not having a parade or anything like that.
They're taking it along the back roads, way on the outskirts.
And the CIA is these helicopters are flying overhead.
They keep intercepting this chatter.
They're getting radio communiques from the convoy, from the Mexican truck convoy to the
Mexican government saying, "Yeah, we have it.
We're headed down these roads."
The spy plane's overhead.
And then the helicopters get word that the convoy has stopped.
It stopped in the middle of the desert on this dusty back road.
The convoy is no longer moving.
And all the radio chatter has stopped as well.
So these four helicopters are flying over the desert and they have no idea what happened.
But they're about to find out.
When the helicopters get there, sure enough, the convoy is completely stopped.
And they notice the helicopter's land and they, again, were very prepared.
This is why people think that they may have done this a few times before.
When they get out of their helicopters, they're wearing biohazard suits.
And they start walking up to the convoy and every single person in that convoy is dead.
Now it doesn't say how many people there were in total.
It does state, the article did state that some of them were dead in their cars, which
would imply that some of them were not in their vehicles when they died.
But what the CIA are now standing among is a mass casualty event.
All of these soldiers are dead and that UFO was still lashed down to the back of this
flatbed truck.
So the CIA just take the UFO, they won't render any aid.
They don't have time to investigate any of this stuff.
They're not supposed to be here.
They were explicitly told to stay away.
We don't need your help.
They bring in that Super Stallion and they actually take the UFO off of the flatbed.
And then all four of these helicopters fly back over the US-Mexican border.
And they take it to this remote location and at this point the CIA attach it to another
flatbed truck.
And then no one knows where it ended.
That's pretty much the end of JS's story.
He says it either went back to Fort Bliss.
It was taken to Wright Patterson Air Force Base in Ohio, which is considered to be the
true home of a lot of reverse engineered UFO craft.
Area 51, this is the conspiracy theory, Area 51 is the decoy.
So it's an interesting thing.
So according to this story it either ended up at Wright Patterson Air Force Base, Fort
Bliss OR the Center for Disease Control.
Because here's the story.
We don't know if this story is true, right?
And we'll get to what we do know is true.
We don't know what killed all of these soldiers.
One of the ideas is it was radiation leaking from the ship that killed them all.
It's possible, right?
You can die pretty quickly if there's enough energy being released.
I don't know if they'll be able to even load it onto the flatbed.
They're like, "Oh, why do I feel so weak?
Why do my bones feel like they're made of paper?"
As they're loading it up.
Some people believe that an alien could have gotten loose or the occupants of the ship,
maybe not just one, could have gotten loose and torn them to pieces.
Another thing that's accepted the most from the story is that it might be some sort of
disease leaking from it.
Because we know that we do that when we come to other places, other countries even, or
other planets are trying to prevent us from bringing diseases.
That maybe these people got some sort of fast-acting disease that wiped them out.
Which in that case you would want to take into the CDC where they could properly contain
it.
You wouldn't want to take it back to Fort Bliss.
That's where all these CIA agents are.
You're like, "Oh, let's just put it in this warehouse and then we'll go eat a hoagie outside
and then they're all dying."
You would want to take it to somewhere where they could contain this.
The question goes, what happened to the convoy?
One theory is that the convoy was cleaned up.
Basically, the Mexican authorities came out there.
They saw everyone was dead, that their UFO was missing.
They either just covered the whole thing up, disposed of the bodies, or they actually destroyed
the convoy.
They blew up the entire area because they didn't know what had caused it in the first
play.
At this point, they would have figured, they would have been like, "Oh, the UFO must have
flowed away."
At this point, they would have picked up that four helicopters went through their airspace.
All their stuff on radar would have picked all this stuff up.
They would have realized the CIA was part of it.
But they have to take care of these bodies.
Since they don't know what killed them and the CIA wouldn't be giving them that information,
they destroyed everything that was out there.
Completely obliterated it from the face of the earth.
They just don't know.
What we do know is, in 1974, on that date, August 25th, 1974, a Cessna did crash in Mexico
in that area.
That's 100% true.
There's debate about whether or not it was a drug plane, or just a plane that was 40
miles off course.
It was joyriding through Mexico.
It's interesting because that's a fact.
That's a fact.
And you can look it up like when I was doing research on this on Wikipedia, they were like,
"Yeah, a lot of people say that a UFO crashed in 1974, but it was really just this drug
plane that went down."
So, you know, it was just that.
We don't know.
It was pretty brief.
It was on the Wikipedia page.
It was like, "UFO..."
What was it?
It was in the Wikipedia page UFO sightings in Mexico.
And it was a fairly incomplete listing.
We've covered more on this show than are in that Wikipedia entry.
But they said, "Yeah, a lot of people think a UFO crashed, but it was really just a Cessna."
That's a weird debunking?
Because no one's denying that a Cessna went down.
They're just saying that it crashed into this UFO.
Something was going on and these two vehicles collided.
But then Robert Biddo was actually looking deeper into this, and he goes, "What's weird
is that it's agreed upon by the skeptics and the UFO community that a Cessna crashed in
the desert?"
That's not what's to debate.
However, he goes, "I cannot find any name of someone who was piloting that plane."
He goes, "Listen, when planes go down," he goes, "Yeah, it was back in the 1970s and
stuff like that."
But they would have the records when that plane left.
That plane had to issue a flight plan.
As we know, it was going from El Paso to Mexico City.
He goes, "There is no record of that plane ever issuing a flight plan.
There's no name of that pilot."
So he goes, "It's weird because even the skeptics agree that a Cessna crashed in the
desert, but I can't find anyone who ever flew this plane.
I can't get any actual concrete evidence that a plane did crash in the desert."
It's very, very weird.
It almost seemed like the better thing for skeptics to do is just say, "The whole thing's
made up.
It's all made up.
It never happened."
The skeptics say, "Yeah, a plane crashed, but it wasn't a UFO and the UFO community
goes, 'Well, the plane crashed and it was a UFO.'"
And Robert Bitto goes, "What plane?
Like I can't find any proof that this plane existed now.
Even if it was a drug runner plane, you do have to issue a flight plan 2.a and then
just fly to point b."
Fascinating story.
It is most likely that the Cessna did crash out in the desert.
What caused it to crash?
Who knows?
It would seem weird that a plane crashing, which it's not super common, but it's also
not terribly rare, would spark such a UFO flap.
But the reason why I really love this story is we get that moment by moment interaction
between these governments over what would happen if a UFO actually crashed.
If it crashed within your borders, you could completely cover it up, especially if it was
in the middle of nowhere.
But when you have to cross international lines to get this disk, because what is the
disk?
Again, 1974, UFOs were considered a joke among the populace, but the US government made
a concentrated effort to make people who reported UFOs a joke.
That's what they did.
They got their fingers in the media, which the government's always controlled the media.
And they said, "Just call a little green man and make these people look like kooks."
But this is the type of stuff that would go on behind the scenes, people fighting for
these artifacts.
And then where did it end up?
Did it release some sort of biological weapon?
And it's in the CDC and they're trying to figure it out, trying to create a cure for
it or trying to weaponize it?
Was it reverse engineered?
Did they take it apart?
It was some sort of Russian spy craft?
Who knows?
And that's kind of the whole thing.
We will never know whether or not we have disclosure tomorrow and alien life is revealed.
I still don't think we'll know about all these little operations over the years.
I don't think they'll be like, "Oh yeah, and then we invaded Mexico to take this disk
and this is what they found."
I think when if disclosure ever does happen, it will be played forward.
They'll never admit they lied to us all these years.
They'll never admit to that.
It's a fascinating story because it shows really what lengths the US government will
go to control access to this information, access to this technology.
They invaded this country.
I mean, it was just four helicopters, but let's call it what it is.
They invaded this country to steal this disk.
What would have happened if the Mexican soldiers, actually, I just thought about this, who's
this thing?
They didn't kill all the Mexican soldiers, right?
And they just go, "Oh, when we got there, their bodies were already riddled with bullets."
I mean, riddled with disease.
And then we blew up the convoy to keep the disease from getting out.
I didn't think about that being a suggestion because what would happen if the CIA of those
helicopters came out and the troops were still alive moving this convoy through?
They would have taken it.
They 100% would have taken that disk.
And it goes to show the lengths that the US government, I really figure any superpower
would go to to contain this technology.
Like if you knew that a vehicle of extra-trust your origin crashed in another country, you
would send people in to retrieve it.
And if those few people couldn't get it, you may actually invade that country in full,
whip up some bizarre reason to go into that country, to restore democracy, and get what
you need.
And while you're there, you know, you can install a dictator and see how that works out.
It doesn't work out well, but at what point would you say, "No, we'll let them have it."
You could not let an other country on Earth have access to this type of technology.
That is how it would work out.
You can have all this talk about disclosure and Congress hearings and people giving these
highfalutin speeches about how we need to know the truth.
But the truth comes with bullets in blood.
The truth comes from agencies like the Central Intelligence Agency taking these things from
people.
We may believe that in the end, having access to this high technology will bring humanity
closer together, will unite us as one people as we explore the stars.
We may believe in the Star Trek future of exploring the cosmos as one people.
But the journey to get there is covered in gore.
It's crafted by countries invading each other to steal this technology.
By taking possible survivors from these crafts and interrogating them the only way we know
how.
We may all want a future where we journey together as one species and explore the universe.
But that journey starts with dozens of dead bodies in a Mexican desert.
Dead Rabbit Radio is the daily paranormal conspiracy and true crime podcast.
We'll see you in the next one.
(upbeat music)